TO THE FINAL YOUR FIRE DRILL OF
THE PRRS
I'M MATT CAMP, WELCOME IN TO OUR
FOURTH AND FINAL SHOW.
IF YOU DRAFTED ALREADY, SEND
YOUR QUESTIONS IN WE'LL GET TO
YOUR QUESTIONS.
MAYBE WITH THE EXTRA TIME
BETWEEN THE PRESEASON AND
REGULAR SEASON YOU HAVE DRAFTS
COMING UP.
I CAN HELP YOU THERE.
WE CAN TALK ABOUT RISERS AND
FALLERS, PRESEASON AND INJURIES,
GET YOUR QUESTIONS IN, I'LL BE
ANSWERING THEM THROUGHOUT THE
ENTIRE SHOW.
LET'S JUMP INTO IT.
INJURIES WE HAD BIG ONES AT THE
END OF THE PRESEASON WE'LL START
WITH YOUR QUESTION HERE.
JAY 44, I DRAFTED J.K. DOBBINS,
WHAT DO I DO?
SORRY.
TO ANYONE THAT DRAFTED J.K.
DOBBINS, SORRY.
YOU KNOW INJURIES WILL HAPPEN.
STUFF WILL HAPPEN IN THE REGULAR
SEASON BUT THIS HAPPENED IN THE
FINAL PRESEASON GAME SO WHAT
NOW?
WHAT IF YOU INVESTED A TOP THREE
OR FOUR ROUND PICK IN J.K.
DOBBINS, DON'T PANIC.
DON'T MAKE A BLOCKBUSTER TRADE.
IF YOU DO THAT YOU'LL HURT
YOURSELF ELSEWHERE.
POINTS DON'T MATTER WHERE THEY
COME FROM, LOADED AT WIDE
RECEIVER, HAVE ONE OF THE BEST
TIGHT ENDS SOMETIMES THAT MEANS
YOU'RE HURTING ELSEWHERE.
THAT MIGHT BE HAPPENING.
YOU MIGHT BE LOOKING AT YOUR
RUNNING BACK DEPTH CHART GOING
WHAT DO I DO?
YOU MOVE EVERYBODY UP A SPOT.
YOU ARE GOING TO HIT THE WAIVER
WIRE THROUGHOUT THE REGULAR
SEASON, YOU ARE GOING TO WIN A
CHAMPIONSHIP BECAUSE YOU HIT THE
WAIVER WIRE MANY TIMES
THROUGHOUT THE SEASON.
YOU DON'T WANT TO GO INTO THE
SEASON WITH SOMEONE LIKE J.K.
DOBBINS DONE.
BUT DO NOT PANIC, DO NOT MAKE A
BLOCKBUSTER TRADE, I SEE IT
HAPPEN WAY TOO OFTEN AND YOU
HURT YOURSELF ELSEWHERE.
SIT BACK, RELAX, MOVE EVERYBODY
UP YOUR DEPTH CHART AND HIT THAT
WAIVER WIRE.
A GOOD CHANCE SOME BIG NAME WILL
END UP BEING THERE AFTER WEEK
NUMBER ONE.
SO I DRAFTED IRV SMITH JR. WAS
THIS A MISTAKE?
YES, IN HINDSIGHT IT WAS A
MISTAKE BECAUSE THE KNEE INJURY
IS TERRIBLE NEWS FOR IRV SMITH.
I DON'T THINK WE'LL SEE HIM AT
ALL.
I DON'T THINK YOU DRAFTED HIM AS
A TOP EIGHT OR NINE.
HE'S A TALENTED PLAYER BUT NOW
YOU DON'T HAVE HIM.
UNLESS YOU HAD ONE OF THE TOP
FIVE OR SIX TIGHT ENDS I WOULD
SAY YOU'RE PROBABLY GOING TO END
UP WITH AN IRV SMITH OR, YOU
KNOW, A GERALD EVERETT OR A ROB
GRONKOWSKI OR EVAN INGRAM OR
SOMEONE LIKE THAT, AND I'LL PLAY
HIM.
THAT'S WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
LOOK AT THE MATCHUPS, BE
STREAMING, MAYBE YOU HAVE TWO
LOWER END GUYS AND YOU'RE
ALTERNATING THEM, THAT'S WHAT
THE MATCHUP.
IT STINKS YOU DON'T HAVE IRV
SMITH BUT IT'S NOT A DEATHBLOW
TO YOUR TEAM.
I'M OKAY WITH STREAMING TIGHT
ENDS AND HOPEFULLY YOU STICK
WITH ONE OF THEM.
WHAT ROUND WOULD YOU CONSIDER
DRAFTING MICHAEL THOMAS KNOWING
HE HAS THE FOOT INJURY.
HERE'S NEWS ON MICHAEL THOMAS.
HE'S ON THE P.U.P. LIST, WHERE
DO YOU TAKE HIM WITH THAT NEWS?
SECOND TO LAST ROUND, IF YOU
HAVE AN IR SPOT, A ROUND EARLIER
THAN THAT AND YOU THROW HIM ON
THERE.
AS GREAT AS MICHAEL THOMAS HAS
BEEN ONE OF THE BEST IN THE
BUSINESS, REALITY, FANTASY, IT
DOESN'T MATTER.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT GAME SHAPE,
PHYSICAL SHAPE, WHATEVER YOU
WANT TO SAY, MICHAEL THOMAS IS
GOING TO BE IN WHEN HE IS ABLE
TO COME BACK.
WHO SAYS HE'LL BE BACK FOR WEEK
7, THAT'S NOT A GUARANTEE.
EVEN IF HE IS BACK FOR WEEK 7,
WHAT LEVEL IS HE GOING TO BE AT?
DON'T LOOK AT THE NAME VALUE OF
MICHAEL THOMAS, I HAVE A WIDE
RECEIVER ONE WHEN HE COMES BACK.
I WOULD LOVE THAT TO HAPPEN, BUT
I'M NOT BANKING ON IT HAPPENING.
ONE MORE I WANT TO TALK ABOUT,
EVAN INGRAM, CALF INJURIEY, THI
PLAYS INTO THEM AS A WHOLE.
EVAN INGRAM'S NUMBERS TO ME,
WHEN THEY'VE BEEN GOOD HAVE BEEN
BECAUSE OF OPPORTUNITY AND
VOLUME.
I SAY THAT BECAUSE HE'S THE LAST
MAN STANDING AT TIMES, OTHER
INJURIES, THE TEAM IS NOT GOOD
AND WE HAVE TO GO TO INGRAM,
THAT'S NOT GOING TO BE THE CASE
THIS YEAR.
I DON'T KNOW HOW GOOD THE GIANTS
ARE GOING TO BEING, IF THINGS GO
WELL, THEY COULD BE A 10, 11
TEAM, WIN THE EAST, AND HAVE
SOME GOOD FANTASY PRODUCTION
THERE.
BUT WHEN YOU HAVE BARKLEY,
SHEPHERD, EVAN INGRAM IS A GUY.
HE'S BEEN SOMEONE I'VE BEEN
LOOKING FOR REASONS NOT TO
DRAFT, THIS MAKES IT EASIER.
TALK ABOUT THE RISERS AND
FALLERS COMING OFF THE
PRESEASON.
JUSTIN, TOOK A CHANCE ON GERALD
EVERETT BECAUSE HE HAS A BETTER
QB AND DOESN'T HAVE COMPETITION
AT SEATTLE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> IF YOU MEAN AT THE POSITION
OF TIGHT END, SURE I DON'T THINK
YOU'RE WORRIED ABOUT SEATTLE.
BUT THE COMPETITION IN TERMS OF
TOUCHES, THAT WOULD GIVE ME
CONCERN.
BETTER PLAYERS, MORE IMPORTANT
PLAYERS FOR THE SEATTLE OFFENSE.
FOR ME I HAVE EVERETT AT 13.
IS IT A BETTER QUARTERBACK
SITUATION, OF COURSE, IT IS.
BUT I DON'T KNOW IF THE
SITUATION AS A WHOLE IS
OPTIMISTIC FOR GERALD EVERETT
BEING A GREAT TIGHT END.
HE'S THERE, HE'S NOT A RISER OR
FALLER BECAUSE I DIDN'T HAVE HIM
HIGH TO BEGIN WITH.
IS IT CRAZY TO PULL THE TRIGGER
ON NAJEE IN THE FIRST ROUND?
AS WE TALK RISERS AND FALLERS
HERE, I SAY HE'S A RISER BUT I
DON'T THINK A RISER TO PICK
SEVEN.
END OF THE FIRST ROUND, PROBABLY
SOMEWHERE IN THE FIRST HALF OF
THE SECOND ROUND FOR ME.
NAJEE HARRIS BASED ON WHEN HE
PLAYED EVERYTHING LOOKS GOOD.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT A
ROOKIE RUNNING BACK, HE HASN'T
PLAYED BEFORE IN THE NFL I CAN'T
TRUST HIM.
PLENTY OF GOOD ROOKIES COMING
THROUGH AT A HIGH LEVEL.
INCLUDING PLAYERS FROM WEEK ONE,
ZEKE DID IT, CAMARA DID IT.
NAJEE HARRIS IS GOING TO BE
FINE.
SEVEN IS TOO EARLY BUT HE'S
RISEN UP MY BOARD A BIT.
WHAT'S MAC'S DRAFT VALUE AFTER
BEING DECLARED QB 1?
NOT SOMEONE I AM GOING TO GET.
I AM HAPPY AS A WHOLE FOR THE
PATRIOTS, ALL THE FANTASY
PLAYERS THAT MAC JONES IS THE
QUARTERBACK NOT CAM NEWTON.
MAYBE DOWN THE ROAD AS WE LEARN
MORE ABOUT THE OFFENSE, I THINK
IT'S AN OFFENSE SOMEWHAT IN
FLUX, WASN'T GREAT LAST YEAR NOW
GOING TO A ROOKIE QUARTERBACK IN
MAC JONES.
MAYBE LATE IN THE SEASON HE GETS
GOING, MATCHUPS LOOK GOOD, YOU
PICK HIM UP.
MAYBE A QB 2 IN YOUR DEEPER TWO
QUARTERBACK LEAGUES BUT THE
NUMBERS WON'T BE ANYTHING
SPECIAL FROM FANTASY.
BUT HE'LL BE A HELP TO THE OTHER
PATRIOTS AROUND HIM.
GOOD NEWS AS A WHOLE BUT FOR MAC
JONES SPECIFICALLY DOESN'T
MATTER MUCH FOR FANTASY
PURPOSES.
LET'S TALK ABOUT MY RISERS AND
FALLERS.
I WANT TO GO WITH A NAME I
MENTIONED, ALVIN CAMARA HAS
MOVED UP, THAT SOUNDS A LITTLE
RIDICULOUS, I WILL SAY THIS, NOW
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ADAM
SHAFTNER BEING HURT, MICHAEL
THOMAS SIX WEEKS OUT OF THE MIX
HERE, WHO ARE THEY GOING TO?
THEY'RE GOING TO ALVIN CAMARA.
I WOULD ARGUE THAT HE COULD BE
THE NUMBER ONE OVERALL PICK IN
FANTASY FOOTBALL.
BECAUSE TALENT AND OPPORTUNITY,
IF YOU GET BOTH OF THOSE THINGS
YOU HAVE A TOP, TOP TIER PLAYER
THAT'S WHAT CAMARA IS.
FOR THE SAME REASONS THAT
CHRISTIAN McCAFFREY IS GOING
NUMBER ONE IS THE SAME REASONS
YOU CAN MAKE FOR ALVIN CAMARA.
BOTH ON AVERAGE TEAMS AT BEST,
EVEN MORE SO IN THE CASE OF A MA
RARE WHO'S MOVED UP A COUPLE
SPOTS.
ALSO WE JUST TALKED ABOUT MAC
JONES, DAMIAN HARRIS HAS MOVED
UP MY BOARD.
I THINK HE COULD FIND HIS WAY
INTO THE TOP 12 AT RUNNING BACK.
I'VE TALKED ABOUT FOR YEARS
DIFFERENT RUNNING BACKS GETTING
USED BUT SONY MICHEL GETTING
TRADED TO THE RAMS IS HELPFUL.
I THINK HE WILL OUTPERFORM THAT,
ADP IS GOING OFF OF SOMEWHAT NOT
KNOWING ABOUT THE QUARTERBACK,
YOU KNOW, SONY MICHEL STILL
BEING THERE.
I THINK YOU SEE DRAFTS, HE'LL GO
A LITTLE BIT HIGHER BUT HE'S
MOVED UP TO ME, I THINK HE WINDS
UP AS A VOLUME RB-2.
ONE MORE NAME THIS IS ME
THINKING ABOUT IT MORE IS
MATTHEW STAFFORD, HE HAS BECOME
MY QUARTERBACK DRAFT.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO TAKE HIM
EARLY.
YOU SEE WHERE HE IS, 85, HE'S A
RISER ON HIS OWN.
AS I THINK ABOUT IT MORE, HE IS
THE TARGET TO ME AT THE
QUARTERBACK POSITION.
I'M NOT TRYING TO GET MAHOMES OR
JOSH ALLEN BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO
TAKE THEM TOO HIGH.
HE AVERAGED 4,300 YARDS A SEASON
WITH THE RAMS.
THERE'S MORE WITH STAFFORD AS
QUARTERBACK.
I KNOW THEY TRADED FOR SONY
MICHEL AND THEY HAVE DARRYL
HENDERSON BUT STAFF BECOMES THAT
MORE IMPORTANT HE'S A MORE
TALENTED QUARTERBACK THAN JARED
GOFF.
I AM REALLY FEELING MATTHEW
STAFFORD AND I THINK HE HAS A
CHANCE TO FINISH AS A TOP FIVE
QUARTERBACK.
THE ONLY THING THAT HURTS HIM IS
THE LACK OF LEGS.
PLAYERS THAT ARE FALLING FOR ME,
BASED ON WHERE I HAD THEM TO
START THE PRESEASON AND NOW.
I'M GOING TO THROW KENNY GALIDAY
HERE, HAMSTRING INJURY HAS
LINGERED.
THE LACK OF ANY BUZZ FOR THE
GIANTS AS WELL.
NOT A LOT OF EXCITING NEWS ON A
TEAM THAT I THINK WILL STILL BE
EXCITING BUT A LOT OF THINGS
HAVE TO FALL RIGHT.
TO ME NOW KENNY GALIDAY HAS
PUSHED HIM INTO THE WIDE
RECEIVER THREE COMBINATION.
THIS WAS A LOW END WIDE RECEIVER
ONE AT TIMES WITH THE DETROIT
LIONS, TWO AT WORST I SHOULD
SAY.
BUT NOW WITH THIS INJURY, I JUST
WANT TO FEEL BETTER ABOUT THE
GIANTS AND I DON'T.
SO KENNY GALIDAY, REALLY RIGHT
NOW NOT INSIDE MY TOP 25, HE HAS
FALLEN AT THE WIDE RECEIVER
POSITION.
LET'S TALK ABOUT MYLES GASKIN,
EVERYBODY EXPECT HIM TO BE THE
GUY AND I DON'T THINK THAT'S THE
CASE, AT LEAST NOT WHAT WE SAW
IN THE LAST MONTH, THAT COULD
CHANGE.
I WAS HOPING TO GO INTO THE
REGULAR SEASON WITH MYLES GAS
KIN ON TOP OF THE DEPTH CHART
WITH NO CONCERNS WHATSOEVER IN
THE MIAMI BACKFIELD, I CAN'T
FEEL THAT WAY.
WE'RE GOING TO SEE MALCOLM
BROWN, SALVIN AHMED.
I THOUGHT IT WAS HIS JOB TO
LOSE, I DON'T WANT TO SAY HE
LOST IT BUT HE DOESN'T HAVE THE
FIRM GRASP ON IT.
I'M NOT EXCITED ABOUT THE
DOLPHINS ANYWAY.
HE'S DROPPED, I THOUGHT HE WOULD
BE A SOLID RB-2, I WOULD LOOK AT
HIM AS A FLEX PLAY TO START THE
SEASON WITH THE HOPE HIS PLAY
WILL MOVE HIM UP IN THE WORLD.
DeANDRE SMITH THEY BROUGHT HIM
UP LAST WEEK, THIS TEAM STINKS,
THE LIONS ARE NOT GOOD, HE HAS
THE GROIN INJURY, HE'S A FAR
FROM PROVEN PLAYER, THE NUMBERS
WERE FINE LAST YEAR.
I TALKED ABOUT JAMAAL WILLIAMS
LAST WEEK.
ALL OF THESE THINGS CONCERN ME.
COULD HE BE A TOP 15 RUNNING
BACK, I WAS HOPING SO, INITIALLY
THAT'S WHAT I HAD HIM RANKED.
I DROPPED HIM DOWN, I HOPE HE'LL
TURN INTO A SOLID TOP 20 RUNNING
BACK THIS YEAR.
I JUST DON'T FEEL GOOD ABOUT THE
SITUATION.
WHEN YOUR HEAD COACH WANTS TO
RUN THE FOOTBALL TALKING ABOUT
YOUR CONDITIONING MAYBE THAT'S
SMOKE AND MIRROR, COACH SPEAK,
THEY DON'T HAVE TO SAY A WORD TO
US, IT COULD BE LIES.
WHAT I HAVE TO SAY ABOUT SWIFT
AND GALIDAY, THE FIRST OFFICIAL
INJURY REPORT DOES NOT COME OUT
UNTIL NEXT WEEK.
IT COMES OUT EARLY IN THE WEEK
FOR THE BUCCANEERS AND THE
COWBOYS AND THEN WEDNESDAY FOR
THE REST OF THE GAME.
THAT'S WHEN WE'LL GET MORE
CONCRETE INJURY NEWS, UNLESS
IT'S A MICHAEL THOMAS AND THEY
END UP ON THE P.U.P. YOU WON'T
GET THAT UNTIL THE START OF THE
SEASON.
SO SWIFT IS GALIDAY ARE NAMES TO
KEEP AN EYE ON.
LET'S GET TO SOME OF YOUR
QUESTIONS BEFORE WE GET TO MY
TAKEAWAYS.
KHANS WHICH WINNER OF THE
PRESEASON WILL HAVE THE BIGGEST
IMPACT ON HIS TEAMMATES?
MAC JONES, RYAN FITZPATRICK, I
FEEL BETTER ABOUT JAMEIS WINSTON
NOT SAYING HE'S GOING TO BE
GREAT.
BUT TAYSON HILL IS NOT GREAT TO
ME.
NOT SAYING JAMEIS WINSTON WILL
BE GREAT BUT I KNOW WHAT HE CAN
DO OUT THERE AND HE IS A TYPICAL
QUARTERBACK IN THAT WAY.
BETTER NEWS THERE.
HE'S PROBABLY HIGHEST BUT OF ALL
THE NAMES I MENTIONED NOBODY
YOU'RE EXCITED ABOUT FOR FANTASY
PURPOSES, MORE SO REALITY.
ABBY WANTS TO KNOW, WHOSE
PRESEASON SUCCESS WILL TRANSLATE
TO THE REGULAR SEASON?
IS THAT A NAJEE HARRIS?
I THINK THAT'S FAIR.
LOOK, THE PRESEASON YOU LOOK AT
DIFFERENTLY RIGHT NOW BECAUSE
IT'S ONLY THREE GAMES, TEAMS ARE
SMART ENOUGH TO NOT PUT GUYS OUT
THERE BECAUSE THEY DON'T NEED
TO.
SO, YOU KNOW, I LOOK AT ROOKIES
GETTING CHANCES, LIKE MAC JONES
GETTING THE CHANCES AND I THINK
THERE COULD BE SOMETHING THERE.
IT'S NOTHING THAT I REALLY GET
EXCITED ABOUT, THOUGH.
SOMETIMES IT'S NOT GETTING
INJURED AND JUST GOING, OKAY,
THIS TEAM LOOKS GOOD.
THERE'S NOT A LOT OF NEWS ABOUT
THE RAMS OFFENSE, OTHER THAN
WHAT HAPPENED WITH THE RUNNING
BACK, SO YOU GO ALL RIGHT,
NOBODY GOT HURT.
WE'RE FEELING GOOD.
THE FACT WE DIDN'T SEE SAQUON
BARKLEY, THEY'RE PLAYING IT
SMART.
PROBABLY GOING TO BE FINE, GOOD
TO GO WEEK NUMBER ONE.
IT'S ABOUT AVOIDING THE
INJURIES, NOTHING BAD HAPPENING.
I SAY IT ALL THE TIME, IF
THERE'S OFF SEASON NEWS AND IT'S
REAL NEWS, 95% OF THE TIME, IT'S
BAD NEWS.
IF YOU AVOIDED BAD NEWS, I'M
FEELING GOOD ABOUT YOU.
AS LONG AS NOTHING REALLY WENT
WRONG AND RANKINGS CAN STAY AS
THEY ARE FROM A McCAFFREY ORCA
MAI
-- OR A KAMARA, OKAY THINGS
LOOK GOOD.
WHOSE STOCK RISES THE MOST
BECAUSE OF OTHER PLAYERS'
PRESEASON INJURY?
WE TALKED ABOUT DARRYL
HENDERSON.
GUS EDWARDS IS OBVIOUSLY THE
HOTTEST NAME RIGHT NOW.
WITH J.K. DOBBINS OUT FOR THE
YEAR AND I DID MENTION THIS WITH
DOBBINS.
I THOUGHT GUS EDWARDS WOULD STAY
INVOLVED, THE RAVENS USED
EDWARDS, USED DO BINS AND LAMAR
JACKSON, WHICH YOU CANNOT
FORGET.
ALL OF THESE GUYS ARE GOING TO
TOUCH THE BALL IN THE BACKFIELD.
BUT GUS EDWARDS BECAUSE THE
RAVENS ARE A RUN FIRST TEAM,
THAT'S NOT GOING TO CHANGE, THE
BOTTOM LINE IS THIS IS A RUN
FIRST TEAM.
GUS EDWARDS AT THE FRONT OF THE
LINE, THE TEAM TRUSTS HIM, HE
HAS PROVEN, HE HAS TAKEN THE BIG
LEAP I THINK HE CAN FINISH
INSIDE THE TOP 15 THIS REGULAR
SEASON AT THE RUNNING BACK
POSITION.
SOME OF MY TAKEAWAYS LET'S GET
TO THESE.
I THINK AND I KNOW THAT CARSON
WENTZ AND THE O-LINE LOOKS
BETTER THEY'RE OFF THE COVID
LIST.
I'M NOT IN ON THE COLTS.
I'M LOOKING FOR REASONS TO NOT
DRAFT JONATHAN TAYLOR.
YOU'RE GOING TO LOOK AT ME, HE'S
RANKED INSIDE THE TOP 14 OF YOUR
RUNNING BACKS, HE'S GOING IN THE
TOP ROUNDS.
THAT'S RIGHT.
BUT THERE'S TOO MUCH TO PROVE
HER FOR THE COLTS WITH THE
O-LINE ISSUES.
HILTON NOW OUT OF THE MIX.
DO YOU FEEL GREAT ABOUT THE
RECEIVERS WHO HAVE DEALT WITH
ISSUES IN RECENT YEARS?
THERE'S NOT A LOT HERE THAT I'M
EXCITED ABOUT, AND I FEEL LIKE
THIS IS A TEAM THAT'S GOING TO
TAKE SOME TIME TO GEL AND FIGURE
IT OUT.
THAT MIGHT MEAN IT'S A LOT OF
JONATHAN TAYLOR AND I HOPE
THAT'S THE CASE.
IF I'M LOOKING FOR TIE BREAKERS,
IF IT'S AN AARON JONES OR A
JONATHAN TAYLOR WHEN IN DOUBT
I'M GOING WITH THE BETTER TEAM.
IF IT'S JONATHAN TAYLOR OR A
WIDE RECEIVER PUSHING DOWN THE
BOARD, WHETHER IT'S TYREEK HILL
OR STEPHAN DIGGS YOU MAY SAY I'M
GOING TO PLAY IT SAFE AND TAKE
ONE OF THEM RATHER THAN JONATHAN
TAYLOR.
THE BRONCOS COULD BE SNEAKY GOOD
FOR FANTASY.
TEDDY BRIDGEWATER GETS THE START
YOU FEEL GOOD ABOUT JERRY JUDY,
PORTLAND SUTTON LOOKED LIKE HE
WAS GOOD TO GO AT THE END OF THE
PRESEASON.
THE BACKFIELD COULD BE A LITTLE
ANNOYING WE'LL SEE.
I LIKE NOAH FAN, I'VE ALWAYS
LIKED HIM, THERE'S A LOT OF GOOD
THINGS HERE.
TEDDY BRIDGEWATER I THINK IS
HYPED UP SOMETIMES TOO MUCH.
PEOPLE THAT LIKED HIM COMING OUT
OF COLLEGE AND NEVER GAVE UP ON
HIM.
HE CAN DO IT.
I THINK HE'S A BETTER PLAYER
SEALING WISE THAN A DREW LOCK,
WHICH IS BETTER THAN EVERYONE
AROUND HIM.
I KIND OF LIKE DENVER, IF YOU
LOOK AT THE DIVISION AND THE
DEFENSES THEY FACE WITH THE
CHIEFS AND THE RAIDERS, YOU
KNOW, I DON'T GET TOO SCARED OFF
ABOUT IT.
THE CHARGERS, BETTER DEFENSE
THERE OBVIOUSLY AS WELL.
I LIKE THE BRONCOS FOR FANTASY
AND YOU DON'T HAVE TO MAKE ANY
MASSIVE INVESTMENTS WHERE THE
ADP IS RIGHT NOW.
ONCE AGAIN, THIS GOES BACK, THIS
IS A BUMMER BUT IT'S REALISTIC.
WE'RE BACK TO A HANDFUL OF TIGHT
ENDS.
YOU HAVE KITTLE AND KELCE AND
WALLER AND HOCKINSON.
BUT AFTER THAT THERE'S A LOT OF
QUESTIONS, WHETHER IT BE NOAH
FAN, WE TALKED ABOUT EVAN
INGRAM, ROB GRONKOWSKI WHERE
DOES HE FIT, DALLAS PRETTY
SOLID.
YOU WOULD LIKE TO SEE ERNST GET
TRADED AWAY BUT THAT DIDN'T
HAPPEN.
IF YOU GET ONE OF THOSE FIVE OR
SIX TIGHT ENDS EVERYONE IS
EXCITED ABOUT YOU SHOULD HAVE A
BIG ADVANTAGE.
IF YOU DON'T, IT'S OKAY.
PROBABLY PLAYING THE STREAMING
GAME.
IF YOU GET ONE OF THE TOP FIVE
OR SIX, YOU HAVE AN ADVANTAGE.
WE'RE BACK TO A HANDFUL OF TRULY
ELITE TIGHT ENDS.
YOU GUYS MAY HAVE DRAFTED
ALREADY.
IF THAT'S THE CASE YOU HAVE
TEAMS YOU NEED ME TO LOOK AT.
LET'S LOOK AT WHAT TEAMS LOOK
LIKE AFTER DRAFTS ARE DONE HERE.
YOU HAVE SENT ME YOUR ROSTERS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF MY TEAM,
AARON RODGERS, DEVONTAE ADAMS,
THE DOUBLE RAINBOW LOVE IT.
JUSTIN, JEFFERSON, PITTS, CLAY
POOL, I DON'T CARE, NEITHER DO
YOU.
BENCH IS LOOKING GOOD, LANDRY,
WHAT ELSE, MALCOLM BROWN,
BEASLEY, CARR.
I DON'T THINK YOU NEED, FIRST OF
ALL TEXAS NATION, GOOD JOB ON
YOUR TEAM.
THIS IS A VERY STRONG TEAM AND
YOU'RE NOT REALLY WORRIED ABOUT
TOO MUCH.
YOU'RE GREAT AT EVERY POSITION.
CLAYPOOL AS A FLEX IS GOOD.
YOU DON'T NEED TO KEEP DEREK
CARR AROUND YOU HAVE AARON
RODGERS.
GRAB A LOTTERY TICKET.
TEXAS NATION, YOU GOT A GREAT
TEAM THERE BUT A GUY LIKE CARR
KIND OF USELESS ON THE ROSTER
BECAUSE YOU HAVE A NUMBER ONE
QUARTERBACK ALREADY IN AARON
RODGERS.
LET'S SEE ANOTHER TEAM HERE.
FIRST PICK IN THE TEN MAN.
SO LET'S SEE.
WHERE DID YOU GO WITH THAT?
YOU WENT WITH -- WHAT RUNNING
BACK IDID YOU TAKE?
I THINK YOU TOOK McCAFFREY.
AARON RODGERS AGAIN.
MYLES STANDARD WHO'S NOT GETTING
A LOT OF LOVE, DK METCALFE,
KIDMAN, HARRIS, THIS IS A GOOD
TEAM.
ONCE AGAIN A GOOD TEAM HERE.
TEN TEAM I'LL TELL YOU THIS, IF
YOU GO INTO THE REGULAR SEASON
IN A TEN TEAM AND YOU ARE BAD
YOU DID SOMETHING WRONG.
YOU SHOULD PRETTY MUCH HAVE A
GOOD TEAM IN A TEN TEAM.
THIS IS A GOOD TEAM ON PAPER.
THE DEPTH, COOPER KUPP ON YOUR
BENCH IS GREAT.
IT'S A GOOD TEAM, SOLID TEAM
THERE, PICKING OUT OF THE NUMBER
ONE SPOT.
I'D BE HAPPY WITH THIS.
YOU FEEL GOOD ABOUT IT BUT THINK
ABOUT THE WAIVER WIRE, A LITTLE
LIGHT AT RUNNING BACK, NOT
AWFUL.
KEEP AN EYE ON THE RUNNING BACK
SPOT.
ONE MORE HERE, TEN TEAMER,
PICKED 7, KYLER MURRAY, JOHNSON,
JONATHAN TAYLOR BUT JAMES
ROBINSON, THERE'S A SPOT I DON'T
FEEL GREAT ABOUT GISICKI IS ON
THE CUSP.
YOU HAVE MIKE DAVIS, SENIOURMAN
MICHAEL THOMAS, CARTER.
YOU HAVE GOOD DEPTH.
I WOULD LOOK AROUND.
I WOULD SAY LOOK AROUND THE
TIGHT END, I'M NOT SAYING MAKE A
TRADE BUT YOU DON'T HAVE TO
STICK WITH GISSIKI, THE REST OF
THE TEAM IS SO GOOD, YOU HAVE
THE NUMBER ONE WIDE RECEIVER IN
DEVONTAE ADAMS.
DIONTAE JOHNSON A SOLID TWO,
OBVIOUSLY A LOT OF MOUTHS TO
FEED IN PITTSBURGH BUT YOU'RE SO
LOADED THERE.
A LOW END RB ONE IN JONATHAN
TAYLOR, HIGH END IN JAMES
ROBINSON.
YOU HAVE SOME DEPTH THERE.
I WOULD LOOK AROUND AT TIGHT
END.
I WOULD SAY I'M INTERESTED IN
TIGHT END, WHAT DOES SOMEBODY
HAVE TO GIVE ME?
I'M NOT RUNNING TO MAKE A TRADE
THERE, THOUGH.
TEN TEAMER THEY SHOULD LOOK GOOD
BUT YOU'LL HIT THE WAIVER WIRE
AT SOME POINT.
IT'S JUST THE NATURE OF FANTASY
NOWADAYS.
>>> BURNING QUESTIONS HERE AS WE
FINISH UP OUR FINAL SHOW SEVEN
DAYS BEFORE THE START OF THE
REGULAR SEASON.
WHO DO I DRAFT WITH THE FIFTH
PICK IN A 10 TEAM?
LET'S THINK ABOUT WHAT THE DRAFT
COULD LOOK LIKE.
McCAFFREY GOES, COOK GOES, ALVIN
CAMARA, MAYBE ZEKE IS GONE
THERE, MAYBE DERRICK HENRY IS
GONE THERE.
IF THOSE NAMES ARE GONE, I AM
HAPPY TO TAKE DEVONTAE ADAMS AT
FIVE, SAFE, INTEGRATED OFFENSE,
AARON RODGERS IS BACK.
IF YOU GET DEVONTAE ADAMS AT
FIVE, YOU'RE GOOD TO GO.
DON'T FEEL LIKE YOU HAVE TO TAKE
A RUNNING BACK IN THE FIRST FIVE
PICKS.
A LITTLE HIT TO DERRICK HENRY,
IS HE THE BEST RUNNING BACK IN
REALITY IN THE NFL, HE COULD BE
BUT NOT GOING TO HAVE A BIG ROLE
IN THE PASSING GAMES AND JULIO
JONES THERE AS WELL.
LET'S GET ANOTHER ONE HERE FROM
TIM.
TIM HAS A QUESTION ABOUT THE
CHIEFS.
WE HAVE PATRICK MAHOMES OR
TRAVIS KELCE?
I WILL TAKE TRAVIS KELCE, NOT
TEN TIMES, NOT 50 TIMES, BUT 100
TIMES OUT OF 100, TAKING TRAVIS
KELCE.
YOU NEVER HAVE TO TAKE A
QUARTERBACK EARLY.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO DO IT.
TRAVIS KELCE IS GOING TO BE A
FIRST-ROUND PICK, MAYBE TOP OF
THE SECOND ROUND PICK.
HE'S GOING TO GIVE YOU AN
ADVANTAGE AT THE TIGHT END
POSITION AND YOU CAN GET
SOMEBODY LATER ON.
GET AARON RODGERS, MATTHEW
STAFFORD, TOM BRADY.
I KNOW MAHOMES IS GREAT.
I GET IT.
BUT YOU DON'T HAVE TO TAKE A
QUARTERBACK EARLY.
GIVE ME TRAVIS KELCE, THE NUMBER
ONE TIGHT END IN FANTASY
FOOTBALL AND LET ME BUILD AROUND
HIM.
YOU USE AN EARLY PICK ON
QUARTERBACK YOU'RE GOING TO HURT
YOUR TEAM.
IT'S GONE THIS WAY FOREVER.
YOU LOOK AT ANY INDUSTRY DRAFTS
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO SEE EXPERTS
GO EARLY.
YOU CAN FIND THAT POSITION, FILL
IN THAT POSITION OR DRAFT IT
LATER ON.
A COUPLE MORE QUESTIONS HERE,
ONE MORE QUESTION I HAVE TO SAY
AS WE WRAP THINGS UP HERE, THIS
COMES IN FROM FREDDY, TRADE
TRAVIS KELCE FOR PARIS GAMBLE?
NO.
YOU ARE TRADING AWAY THE BEST
PLAYER, I KNOW ROBERT TONYAN
PROBABLY IN THE TOP TEN COMFORT
BUT PARIS CAMPBELL, IS HE ON TOP
OF THE DEPTH CHART FOR THE
COLTS?
HE COULD BE.
THINK ABOUT TARGETS.
I KNOW MIKE PITMAN IS THERE AS
WELL.
BUT I'M TRADING AWAY THE BEST
PLAYER IN THE DEAL, GUS EDWARDS
IS SOLID.
WE KNOW HIS STOCK IS ON THE RISE
AS A WHOLE AS WE LOOK AT THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE DEAL, IT
DOESN'T GIVE ME EXCITEMENT.
MIKE WILLIAMS IS FINE, GUS
EDWARDS IS MORE THAN FINE.
YOU'RE TRADING AWAY A STAR
CALIBER PLAYER, LEAGUE PLAYER,
STUD, ONE OF THE BEST IF NOT THE
BEST AT THE POSITION AND YOU GET
PIECES BACK.
IF I'M TRADING AWAY TRAVIS KELCE
I WANT TO BE FIRED UP ABOUT MY
RETURN.
I'M NOT FIRED UP ABOUT GUS
EDWARDS, MIKE WILLIAMS AND
ROBERT TONYAN, I'M GUESSING
YOU'RE HURTING AT RUNNING BACK,
MAYBE YOU HAD J.K. DOBBINS BUT
YOU'RE HURTING YOUR TEAM.
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHERE THE
POINTS COME FROM.
IF YOU HAVE A GUY LIKE KELCE YOU
HAVE THE ADVANTAGE AT TIGHT END
EVERYONE WEEK.
I WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY FOR
JOINING ME FOR THE LAST FOUR
SHOWS, A LITTLE EXTRA TIME
BETWEEN NOW AND THE START OF THE
REGULAR SEASON.
DON'T TINKER THINGS TOO MUCH,
MAYBE THERE'S CUTS TO BE MADE, A
TRADE TO BE MADE, IN THE NFL NOT
YOUR LEAGUE BUT TAKE YOUR TIME,
LOOK AT THE INJURY REPORTS NEXT
WEEK.
I WANT TO THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN,
HIT ME UP ON TWITTER WITH YOUR
QUESTIONS AT MATT CAMP THERE.
GOOD LUCK TO YOU IN 2021 FANTASY
FOOTBALL SEASON.
I'M MATT CAMP AND THIS IS YOUR
FANTASY FIRE DRILL.